warner de la pandemia el presidente de
eeuu joe biden
superó con creces su objetivo inicial de
aplicar 100 millones de vacunas en sus
primeros 100 días de gobierno ya eran
200 millones de dosis inoculadas para el
21 de abril los ciudadanos totalmente
inmunizados ya no deben usar mascarillas
al aire libre y nueva york anunció su
reapertura total para el primero de
julio
la economía y el congreso aprobó un plan
de estímulo de 1,9 billones de dólares
sin un solo voto republicano millones de
estadounidenses recibieron cheques de
estímulo de 1400 dólares y la economía
registró un crecimiento de 6,4 por
ciento en el primer trimestre en
comparación con el mismo período de 2007
el multilateralismo eeuu está de vuelta
fue el mensaje de bailén tras la era
trump el demócrata ha reanudado los
acercamientos con irán con miras a dar
nueva vida al acuerdo nuclear de 2015 ha
reiterado el compromiso inquebrantable
de washington con la otan y reincorporó
a eeuu al acuerdo climático de parís
cumpliendo su promesa de organizar una
cumbre
a global la migración maiden revocó la
prohibición de viajar a eeuu de personas
provenientes de países musulmanes
fortaleció el plan conocido como daca
sin embargo el giro de las políticas
migratorias hizo que se registrara un
récord de llegadas a la frontera
principalmente de menores no acompañados
hoy por hoy la encargada de liderar la
respuesta de la crisis es la
vicepresidenta kamala harris quien ya
anunció 310 millones de dólares en ayuda
humanitaria para atacar las causas del
éxodo en centroamérica los retos entre
ellos se cuentan cumplir con su promesa
de retirar todas las tropas
estadounidenses de afganistán con el 11
de septiembre como fecha límite hacer
frente a rusia a cuyo presidente
vladimir putin tildó de asesino y lograr
el apoyo del congreso para sus
ambiciosos planes de inversión en
infraestructura y bienestar social de 2
y 1.8 billones de dólares
respectivamente que incluyen aumentos de
impuestos a los más ricos temas que
bardem define como clave para ganar en
el siglo 21 ante china su principal
rival